hospitals destroyed
workers under stress
and a system fighting against the odds
hospitals have been attacked multiple
times a new report reveals the scope of
Russian attacks specifically on Health
Care between February and December of
last year researchers documented more
than 700 attacks on the system including
292 attacks on 218 hospitals 181 on
other health care infrastructure
including pharmacies and research
centers 65 documented attacks on
ambulances 86 on health care workers
including 62 people who died experts say
these numbers keep Rising making it
increasingly difficult to give basic
care the tax on health so fear and
Terror in civilian populations they also
make it more difficult for civilian
populations to access important
medicines vaccinations care for chronic
conditions with the health care crisis
now reaching every corner of the country
sometimes even when hospitals had this
cross on hospital and it was visible
from from the air that it was a hospital
but still it was attacked so today we
have one of three ukrainians that don't
have access to Medicine in Ukraine
Ukrainian Canadians like Gabriella
bunchek say needs are great and supplies
are running thin one truck with 24
pallets of bandages we used that
extremely economically but it goes in
one week still there is commitment and a
drive to keep going the ukrainians are
inspiring organizations around the world
you know with the
not Optimist but kind of like
willingness to fight to the end and the
world is inspiring ukrainians basically
by helping us
we are getting the message from the
world that the world is nothing
different Advocates are calling on the
International Community to ensure Russia
is held responsible prioritize these
these attacks for further investigation
and prosecution and to build cases that
can can ultimately result in
accountability uh for for these
violations Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto